[Music]
welcome to the podcast today we're gonna
do something a little bit different
we're gonna do a version of ask me
anything we're experimenting with the
format a little bit here to try to be
current not only with audience audience
interests but also with the new cycle to
some extent this is something that came
up in my recent podcast with James all
teacher who was encouraging me to share
more of my voice and my perspective and
opinions on things that the audience is
interested in and I expressed to him in
that conversation my discomfort with
just speaking into a microphone alone so
I then reached out to my friend Adam
Skolnick to join me so it could be more
of a conversation and less of a
monologue you guys longtime listeners
will remember Adam he was on the podcast
I can't remember what episode number it
was but it was quite a while ago he is
the author of a book called one breath
about Nick milolii the free diver he's
also a journalist and a writer frequent
contributor to The New York Times
outside magazine anything else all kinds
of different outlets yeah and you write
about environmentalism you write about
endurance sports and a number of other
yeah human rights whatever you know
stories that underreported stories kind
of right that terrain we've been good
friends Adam has recently dipped his toe
into the world of swim run Adams the guy
who wrote the article for the New York
Times about when I did the Otello World
Championships and then you participated
in the the won the swim run in Catalina
recently that's right that's right I did
the experience yeah and and I haven't
stopped running since right and you're
looking super fit hey thanks and I
always enjoyed my conversations with you
and I just thought that you would be a
great person to volley back and forth
with again this format so we're giving
it a go thanks for having me yeah man
great to be here excited to talk to you
today yeah I think a good place to kind
of kick this off is to
directly address this very unique and
historic moment that we're in right now
black lives matter I've been not
struggling that's the wrong word but
trying to figure out the best way to
communicate around what is occurring in
the moments historically this podcast
has been constructed in a way that has
prevented it from being nimble enough
and responsive enough to be of the
moment like the conversations are
typically evergreen right and I will
record lots of conversations and then we
have a production cycle and those
conversations will be released some
weeks later sometimes four six eight
weeks later right in normal times that's
fine
right now that seems to be dysfunctional
because everything is changing so
quickly and I felt this urgent need to
be communicating about what is happening
more concurrently with this rapidly
escalating and changing landscape that
we find ourselves in so this is an
effort to do just that
and I think you know one thing I want to
speak to directly upfront is is you know
some criticism that's been hurled in my
direction my most recent podcast that
went up this past weekend was with my
friend Doug Evans he wrote this book
called the sprout book we talked about
sprouting we did touch on food injustice
but predominantly we spoke about his
book and the nutritious power sprouting
and there were some people who were
ruffled by that and because it's so
asynchronous with what is happening
right now and my immediate reaction is
to be defensive but in truth there's
that's correct right like there it you
know it does feel wrong to talk about
anything but what's occurring in the new
cycle right now and I understand that
and this is what we're doing right now
is
is one way of rectifying that and I do
want to say up front that I have
scheduled numerous people of color to be
coming on the podcast yesterday I did an
amazing episode with my friend
Myron Davis former USA national swim
team member and his friend Phil Allen
jr. who's a pastor and a poet and a
filmmaker we had an incredible
conversation that's going to be going up
late Sunday night
I've got Knox Robinson coming back on
the show I've got John Lewis the badass
of Egan I've reached out to a whole
number of other people including Shaka
Seng Gore Reverend Michael Beckwith some
women of course so that's all going to
be coming but this takes time you know
that's a production cycle here so I
encourage people to be a little bit
patient and also I just want to let
people know that I hear you and I under
and I understand and I think that as I
grapple with how to communicate about
this I went through a period in which I
didn't want to be reactive in the moment
like I wanted to say my piece which I
get in an Instagram post for the moment
but then I also expressed that I wanted
to take the time to also learn and
listen and I've done that our family
went out and protested and I've just
been paying attention to what's going on
so that I can when it when the moment
does arise to speak to this I'm a little
bit more informed and I can respond
intelligently as opposed to reacting
impulsively yeah makes sense I'm you
know I was going through some of the
listener questions and you're talking
about the future guests was it something
that you ever tracked before in terms of
having a diversity of guests or is that
something that you're just kind of
you're noticing now and wanting to pivot
to or is that something that you've been
it's been on your mind for a while and
and yeah it's been on my mind I mean
it's there has been criticism in the
past that the podcast is not diverse
enough mm-hm
and that's come up again more recently
like why is your podcast so white and
and so male-centric and again that's
another instance in which I get
defensive right because I look at my
list of guests that I've had over the
years and I think about Myrna Valerio
and Jacques and Gore and George raveling
and David Carter and Bryant Terry and
Knox Robinson and David Goggins and
Dominic Thompson and light walkins and
Sean Stephenson and dr. Robin shut kin
and Silas ray oh and you know I can
think of lots I can rattle off like a
lot of african-american guests that I've
had yeah but when you look at the Canon
of the work five hundred and twenty plus
episodes it doesn't hold up and that's
something that I have to own like I
think that the podcast has a lot of
growth potential in terms of the
diversity of voices that I can bring to
it and I will be the first to admit
right now that I haven't done the best
job with that and that's part of my
learning curve in this moment is being
more sensitive to that truth and that
reality rather than just doubling down
and saying look at all the people that
I've had yeah you know why are you
saying that it's to actually reflect
inward and honestly and objectively and
try to understand where that perspective
is coming from and when I do look at it
objectively I see that point yeah and I
think that there is improvement there
that I need to commit to and so I am
committing to that right now I've
already taken action to you know rectify
that to some regard and I think that
it's important right now to open this up
to a diversity of voices you know this
is not a news podcast and I resist
trying to be you know I've resisted
politics in general and I don't court
controversy but without a doubt this is
an unprecedented historic moment and I
think it's super important to be engaged
in what's happening right now
you know I very much want to be on the
right side of history and I want to get
this right and despite the fact that
this isn't a news podcast at the same
time it is a podcast about conversations
that matter and right now enough
matters more than black lives matter and
what we're seeing unfolding not just
nationally but globally worldwide
totally agree I think and by the way
that question came in from Stacy Alice
Johnson said ona want to make sure that
we acknowledge that but you know when
you're talking about that a couple
things come to mind one is this is a
moment where we all have to do and buy
we all I mean white people have to do
the inner work and examine our own
relationship to race in this country and
I think that it's kind of a this is the
reconciliation moment you know and I
started to think about kind of the the
greater issues here and why it's taken
so long and what this moment means you
know in in after World War two I know
this because as a Jew I know I mean I'm
like well steeped in Holocaust info and
after World War two there was
reconstruction in Germany and around
1960 there was this resurgence of German
nationalism and around that same time
Israel found out that Adolf Eichmann who
is kind of the managing director of all
things Holocaust he he's got he managed
the trains and the schedules
he was found in Argentina and they got
him and they put him on trial all over
the world they could tune in and see him
on trial and in Israel and after that
moment Germany totally changed their
education system towards reconciliation
and to to educate so every year four
years in school Germans have to devote a
substantial amount of time to examine
what happened how they slipped into
nationalism and and what happened in the
Holocaust all the horrors in great
detail and we don't do that you know
we've never really done that you know we
gloss over slavery we gloss gloss over
Jim Crow stuff segregation it's not
taught every year it's not taught in
great detail and it's taught through the
lens of the victors and something it
came up in the podcast yesterday I like
the way that we were educated around
these issues is from a perspective that
is rather myopic
it's the cut those are the covers that
are getting pulled right now yeah
exactly and so you can't if you don't
examine it and it says all the things
it's all about hard truths I mean what
your your your podcast is in the news
podcast but it is how to live better
podcasts it's not just a podcast of
ideas it's a podcast of ideas that you
can relate to and and improve your own
life if you if you take the information
as it is like brain food and decide to
dedicate yourself to it and these are
hard truths that we have not dealt with
in this country and and and so now
people are you know it's very exciting
to see like the top of the bestseller
lists are these you know how to be anti
racists and white fragility and some
some books that are very recent that did
well enough but now are really selling
and that that's I think that's a great
thing because people are now doing their
own education but that doesn't mean that
we shouldn't be doing more systemically
yeah systemically is the key word and
it's this interesting juxtaposition on
the one hand you have these massive
protests that are very diverse in their
socio-economic and ethnic makeup you
know it's so interesting to take to the
streets and see you know so many white
people and brown people people of color
people of all shapes and forms uniting
around these ideas and I found myself
much more emotional and I expect it mmm
which is so hopeful yeah heartening at
the same time you go online and the
vitriol and the resistance to these
ideas is of equal force and measure hmm
at times I think that that is going to
you know lose out in the long run but
there is a certain swath of the
population that's very threatened by
this and I'm interested in why that's
the case and my sense is that on some
level there's a perception that it's a
zero-sum game like if we're talking
about black lives matter that that
somehow dismisses the value and
importance of other lives and right now
you know on top
of the you know this this uprising and
awareness were we're also seeing the
greater disenfranchisement of a lot of
people due to unemployment and you know
the the the sort of domino effect of
coronavirus in this pandemic and that's
making people more afraid and more
calcified around their identities and
their sense of you know protecting
what's theirs yeah and so there's an
interesting turf war that's going on
right now and I think so much of that
you know resistance to change or
resistance to you know embracing this
idea that we need significant
Reformation is coming from that place of
fear and disenfranchisement ya know I
think you're right but if you and if you
go back to the whole idea of race I mean
it's obviously an illusion right it's an
illusion created by white people mm-hmm
and it was created by white people for
two basic reasons one is to give
ourselves and I our selves meaning
Europeans at the time license to travel
abroad other other lands other cultures
take the land take the stuff do whatever
they want with it subjugate the people
so why because we were superior in the
eyes of God that was the idea of race
right and think it was created by white
people nobody nobody else created race
so that's one and the other reason was
used to divide people to divide people
up mainly poor white people for years
have been fed this idea of race saying
no you're you know you're better off
then look at these black people over
here in this country anyway look at
these people over here you're better off
you're superior to them and that's what
a lot of people latched on to and that
is allowed the powers that be
whether it be wealthy people whether it
be kings and Lords just wealthy you know
Americans or the power structure to
exploit them
and exploit all of us and so it's
basically a divide and conquer trick
that was created and that's all races
races and illusion and to divide and
conquer trick and now it matters because
it's been baked into the American Way of
life it's like this weird neuroses that
is that has been baked into all of us
and we all have it that's why we're
doing this kind of inner work now
because we grew up and live in a place
where that has been baked into the sauce
yeah and it's a matter of debugging yeah
ourselves like rebooting our operating
systems with you know some kind of
antivirus software to cleanse us of that
and I think that process of looking
inward and evaluating the extent to
which race plays a factor in the
conscious awareness of the average
person is challenging because most
people would consider themselves not to
be racist I don't think that I'm a
racist person I don't you know commingle
or surround myself with racist people
but when the racism is systemic there
are institutions in place that function
in a way irrespective of our own
personal relationship with race that tip
the scales in the wrong direction and
perpetrate these sorts of harms and even
deeper beneath that is that embedded
system that operating system that on a
very unconscious level there is that
awareness of you know stratification
around race then is and that's very
uncomfortable you know like say you know
what what what part of my own psyche is
functioning on that operating system and
how can I deconstruct that or how can I
get honest with myself about that so
that I can transcend that and I think a
lot of people take offense to that
because they think they're not racist
and there is no work to be done but I
would challenge everybody to do that's
what I'm trying to do right now I'm
trying to be honest about that and a
perfect example is like well just look
at all the guests that I've had on the
podcast mostly white people right I mean
so what's going on with me I'm not a
racist person but but here's the
manifestation of my life's work and that
a story right so what is that story
that's being told and what aspect of
that has to do with race and that's like
that's the hill that I need to climb
right now yeah I mean you know we're all
grappling with our implicit biases
biases and that just happens like
because we do have this weird overt
awareness of race that that isn't
serving any anybody especially black
people and like Toni Morrison I just saw
Tony Morrison clip from the old Charlie
Rose show and and she was like you know
but you know she she flipped it and she
was like no what's that doing to you
white people because I'm fine right um
well Charlie asked her something like is
race still a thing for you because
you're this Pele it surprised winning
you know I Herald it you know poet
laureate like you've transcended race
yeah and she said that's the wrong
question yeah the wrong that's the wrong
question what's what what how do you
white people have to deal with race and
and it's almost like if you can only be
taller than me because I'm on my knees
what's that say about you mm-hmm and
your significance and and so that and
but if you if you look at the story of
America that's really the story I'm I
was watching this
Ken Burns documentary about Jack Johnson
the boxer last night and to see how the
LA Times in New York Times were writing
about him the greatest athlete because
at the time heavyweight boxing was the
pinnacle of sorts the greatest athlete
in sports you'd be surprised how
vitriolic it was how racist it was and
these are you know I'm right in the New
York Times but you don't even know that
right we don't know that as modern
Americans that that's that's how overt
it was right that like there was
straight-up racist stuff in news stories
you know we talk about fake news now
because Trump's always talking about
fake news and he's delivering and
retweeting fake news and we had actual
fake news affect our election 2016 black
Americans have been dealing with fake
news for hundreds of years right stuff
that they know has happened to them
reported as false in the mainstream
media mmm for years and years
you know this is nothing new so you know
I don't know where I got on that tangent
but yeah well they you know it goes back
to you know history is told by the
victors there was an interesting threat
on Twitter and I'm forgetting who posted
it but it was a very long thread about
Martin Luther King and the extent to
which white America embraces him and
pivots around his message of
non-violence but this sort of broke down
a different reality about what his
message was about
yes non-violence was part of it but but
what gets missed in that is that it was
all about civil disobedience and with
that we're talking you know civil yes
but disobedient right making people
uncomfortable was a big part of it not
protesting where they tell you you can
protest but protesting where they tell
you you can't right and that gets lost
in the conversation around MLK I mean
that's just one example and I think
another flare-up that we're seeing right
now is the conversation around defunding
the police yeah there's a lot of people
are upset about that like oh you want to
get rid of the police that's not what
defunding means defunding could mean a
lot of things but I think what it really
is getting at is the core dysfunction in
the systemic institution of policing to
begin with which in which is very much a
community-based thing but it goes back
to what you were saying earlier about
erecting mechanisms of control to
solidify power structures yeah I mean
see protect and serve but really
fundamentally that's what it's about and
it's become a you know highly
dysfunctional in our current era and
defunding is a call to have a
conversation about the fundamental
purpose of policing and the allocation
of resources to drive towards a more
productive goal for everybody yeah you
know I was I was I wrote something down
here so I'm just kind of like sifting
through but like these big ideas are
very exciting they scare people I mean
the defunding police talk does scare
some people especially more conservative
people but the
these it's these big ideas are inspiring
and we should stay open to them because
I think what what defunding the police
and really we're just talking about
cutting budgets no you know in very few
cases is it talking about abolishing a
police nobody nobody's talking no it's
talking about cutting budgets right and
I think personally I mean this is just
my personal opinion that we've for a
long time have had a skewed budget
towards militarization and the national
level I've always thought God why don't
we take some of that military budget and
put it into our underfunded schools and
pay teachers more yes services or
programs and until he'll and and the
funny thing is I always thought about it
as a national thing but it's gonna start
now with the police because of the
activists in the streets because of
black lives matter this is where it
starts and I think we're gonna see if
this if we can push this and continue
continue the protests and continue the
lobbying efforts and having lawmakers
get on board if we can see it at the at
the local level moving some money from
militarization and enforcement and and
basically let's call it what it is
weapons and death yeah and move it
towards nurturing and nurturing life and
and giving people a better chance at a
great life through education and and
through healthcare I think we're gonna
see a better country come out of it so
it's funny the thread of defunding the
police could be the the trick you know
that's what it is if you can if the
thread is white supremacy and you can
start pulling it through the defunding
the police what else what can happen to
this country in a positive way and I
think that's that's the big idea to
think about we're already seeing it
Minneapolis has already done that yeah
it basically said we're stripping this
thing down to its to its you know to its
studs and we're gonna rebuild this from
the ground up and I believe Camden New
Jersey is kind of a pilot program
example you have that they've done
something similar yeah in that regard
and and I guess that's something where
you can call 911 but you can choose
police or mental health responders yeah
first responders yeah it's super
inspiring yeah you know at the same time
we're
this malignant narcissist in the White
House who's you know constructed a wall
around his domicile it's not domicile
yeah right it's the people's domicile
right yeah
ensconced in this building well he's you
know basically pulled out every trick
from the the you know despots handbook
to activate his base and my sense is
that it's backfiring right now there
were all there always be you know his
people who are gonna support what he's
doing but there are significant cracks
and that firmament at the moment you
know I don't think that the average
person takes kindly to seeing the extent
of militarization in the streets to
police its own people
and armies battalions of essentially
soldiers who won't tell you who they
work for who they report to or Bob Barr
out there pretending like he's Patton or
something you know I it's it's
disturbing and I think most rational
people are struggling with what that
means and what that says about America I
think so I mean I think you were talking
about the hardcore people that are
resistant look at Buffalo Police
Department and how how I think they
demonstrate this mass resignation from
the riot squad because two people pushed
over a 75 year old man instead of just
dealing with him in a more peaceably way
it was seven of them yeah they didn't
they didn't resign they got reassigned
right right they equipped a riot squad
and then a hundred people showed up for
the arraignment of those two officers
and they cheered them and it just shows
you there's a there's a sensitivity
especially among cops and police around
the country but in this hardcore group
they're very sensitive they don't want
to talk about these things they're
resistant and I think even you know a
lot of us don't want to be piled with a
bunch of guilt you know and it does you
know we're no one's talking about this
to make anyone feel guilty it's it's
about making us
responsible guilt is a worthless emotion
responsibility is where you want to go
right liked it what can we do to make it
better and and you know channeling it
into efforts like banning chokeholds do
you know cutting the police budget so
that it can go to I think we should talk
about not just defunding police but what
are we funding with it right and and and
I think that's part of the equation you
know funding schools in a more profound
way making sure people have enough to
eat you know just making sure we have a
safer place for everybody yeah to live
yeah and we get to have that
conversation yeah you know what I mean
we were talking yesterday about the work
that DeRay McKesson is doing with a
can't wait and campaign zero and he's
very much about you know data-driven
solutions to the police force and and
you know what's required to you know in
a very tactical way to deconstruct some
of these practices that are leading to
the harms and the results that we're
seeing right now and I think a broader
conversation about you know where this
money is going so that we can redress
homelessness and we can redress you know
everything from college debt to mental
health yeah I mean if if there was a
social worker in that police car in
Minneapolis also to deal with the first
car the first car that showed up to deal
with someone who is who was struggling
and didn't want to get into that car
because he was claustrophobic if there
was someone and the same is true all the
way down the line if there's if there is
a mental health first responder in a car
with a policeman what does that do mmm
who does that benefit it's not gonna
just benefit the these these victim
would be victims of police violence it's
gonna benefit the cop as well it
benefits everybody because now you don't
have that on your conscious on your soul
so I mean I think these ideas of
incorporating mental health into
policing or into the way we protect one
another because it's not just protecting
the neighborhood it's protecting one
another
right yeah and just to be clear I'm not
anti police you know I'm not a there are
plenty of amazing police officers and
first responders and and you know all
that all the kind of you know people
that we need to you know keep society
you know on the right track but I do
resist the bad-apple narrative like
there's a lot of talk about bad apples
and certainly there are bad apples but
what we saw with with George Floyd was
was you know I said this yesterday like
it was so brazen right and that the
casualness with which that harm was
perpetrated that murder and you know the
fact that there were the other officers
who were who were just standing by and
doing nothing speaks to a greater
systemic issue that needs to get
redressed and I think that you know I'm
sure it's you know community base but
the bar to becoming a police officer I
feel like needs to be raised like you
don't become a Navy SEAL until you go
through buds right you go through
rigorous training to become somebody
who's capable of handling high-stress
situations that could potentially
escalate and be violent yeah and I would
like to see more rigorous standards
around who gets to become a police
officer these are people who are putting
themselves in harm's way on the daily
yeah and with that comes anxiety and
stress and post-traumatic stress and all
these you know mental issues and we want
those people to be mentally emotionally
and spiritually fit to handle those
situations to understand what's required
to avoid excessive force or lethal force
when it all possible and that you know
it's common sense that that requires
better training when we're seeing what's
happening right now it speaks to a lack
of understanding and training around
these skill sets that are crucial yeah I
mean this the idea of when a crisis hits
is your pulse rate go up or does it go
down you know we want people who's
pulse rates go down who can who can stay
on task in the midst of of trying
circumstances and aren't afraid of them
and and if they are afraid
don't act it's okay not to act sometimes
it's okay to pull back you know the fact
that we have lost someone because he
spent a counterfeit $20 bill is is
repulsive you know the fact that like
that he was even dealt with in any
physical way mm-hmm when you could just
write a ticket for something like that
is ridiculous yeah so it's like it's
it's that that goes into the training of
exerting a physical will on another
human being there should be limits on
when we do that that should be a last
resort not a first resort in my opinion
but you know I think that if we think
about George Floyd and and going back
and you're talking about the new cycle
earlier I don't want to ask you a
question about this but you know first
we have this long really boring
pre-apocalypse moment with with everyone
staying at home right with the pandemic
right and everyone's kind of at home and
it seems like oh wow you know we're
looking at videos of dolphin becoming in
sourdough bread right we're making
sourdough bread it's like it's this long
kind of like kind of low-key type thing
and then overnight the it's it flips but
it started not with George but it
started with a mod arburian and words
and we want for me you know I'm a runner
like you not like you I'm not a runner
like you yeah you are I'm a runner I got
a back injury now but but a mod I mean
very personal like during during where I
live in Santa Monica the beach path was
closed so I start running into these
neighborhoods and I'm running into you
know tax brackets that I don't belong in
and I never once felt unsafe doing it
and or like that it wasn't that it
wasn't okay and then we had them on our
Berea what is you know I know you posted
that great video on your Instagram
but I just wondered what you think of
now because who would have thought then
and now it leads to this but it is part
of a part of what's happened I mean that
was the first yeah for these things yeah
there there is a domino effect here in
it and and and this episode that we're
seeing began with a mod and it's
horrific in every regard and I think you
know to the point of looking at my own
behavior around this I feel like I
didn't speak up around that at that time
you know I was late to the party on that
in terms of putting words together in
the public conversation around it and I
should have done that you know as a
runner as somebody who could identify
you know with that aspect of who that
human being was it's unbelievably tragic
and in reflecting upon that you know
it's very clear my privilege becomes
very clear because I've run all over the
world
I've run you know not just the trails
around my house but I've had the
privilege of traveling to lots of
different places and whatever hotel I'm
staying in my favorite thing when I go
to a new city is just to put on my
running shoes and run around it and
never once did I ever think I'm putting
myself in harm's way no matter where I
am you know and when I posted that the
other day there were some snarky
comments like well that's because you
know you're not running through watts
and you're not running through Compton
we have an apartment downtown because my
daughter goes to a high school right
next to downtown and that apartment is
around the corner from Skid Row and I
make a point of running through Skid Row
on purpose because I want to see what's
going on there
and I've never felt threat in fact
people when I run through Skid Row for
the most part and I've said this before
there people are nicer to me than they
are out on the trail like when I'm out
on the trail and I wave to somebody and
they don't wave back like what the [ __ ]
right I run through Skid Row and I'm
giving high fives to these people who
live in tents and you know that's you
know a potentially dangerous
neighborhood now you know yeah no I'm
not running through Compton everyday or
anything like
like I understand that's a different
thing but the point is that I don't have
to think about that or worry about that
and I've been pulled over by the cops so
many times in my lifetime when I was you
know out-of-control alcoholic I got
pulled over for DUI tons of times never
once not only was I not afraid of
anything happening to me by the cop I
got let off like tons of times when I
should have gone to jail or then
arrested so many times and you know I've
run in the Middle East I've run like
I've run all over the place and I've run
through you know I've run through Beirut
Lebanon in weird neighborhoods and you
know places where you know I'm I am the
minority and never thought once about
like my own personal safety because it's
not the law enforcement apparatus isn't
geared towards you and that what about
ISM is is kind of people again not
wanting to listen because it's hard to
hear you know I mean I think you he
talked about David Goggins you know
obviously I right when we were giving
your CV at the beginning I left out like
this that you you were in cooperation
partnership with David wrote his book
can't hurt me which is still like the
number one book in the world crazy and
you did the audiobook with yeah I
narrated an audio book and I mean his
he's such a masterful storyteller the
way he tells his story but one thing he
is not afraid to do is look at himself
with a microscope and and talk to
himself in a way that's real and you
know the the approach that you want to
take when when people are telling you
something isn't well what about this
what about that is to listen and to look
into yourself before you say what about
what about I mean like a great example
of systemic racism in this country is
you know we remember when all the gunmen
came around the Michigan State House to
the guys with the ar-15 all that and
people were talking about it you know if
that was people of color if those were
black men it would have been National
Guard they would
know that it got me think of California
gun laws because you know California is
one of the best gun control measures in
the United States and do you know who
passed those gun laws Oh hoo Reagan in
the 1960s Reagan was governor and he
passed those gun laws with the full
cooperation and support of the NRA
because Black Panthers did try to come
to the state capitol with guns to do a
demonstration the guns were removed and
they still came and they stormed the
capital and they were able to break in
to the actual floor of the State House
well legislation what's going on the
legislative session was going on and
then those people were arrested and then
soon after that they actually passed gun
control measures in in California wasn't
Democrats who passed those measures it
was Reagan mm with the full cooperation
of NRA there's no real better episode
from history to show you that we
couldn't even pass gun control measures
in this country after Sandy Hook mm-hmm
so that just shows you kind of like how
the system is played out and and lean
you know as much as anything in my
opinion yeah it shows you how it's how
it tilts another interesting wrinkle to
the issue of guns when you look at the
Second Amendment and the intention
behind that which was to empower the
people to rise up against a corrupt
government now we're seeing the the
deployment by the government of
basically a private militarized police
force which is the very thing that the
founding fathers had in mind in terms of
ensuring that the people would be able
to resist just such a thing but the
people who are the most supportive and
vocal about gun rights and the NRA are
the ones who are the most supportive of
the despotic move by the government
right now yeah and there's an inherent
irony in that which is you know kind of
amazing it's so weird you know I was
watching
my wife is six months pregnant so I've
been very careful during quarantine and
not have not attended the demonstrations
not out of a lack of wanting to be there
but just out of being super careful and
it's really exciting to see how many
everyone is activists now I've been in
and around activism mostly in the
environmental side for you know most of
my adult life and to see everyone become
an activist is very exciting and to want
to be there but not first I was watching
it very intently as it started unfolding
in Los Angeles that first Saturday
around Fairfax and there was no looting
in Los Angeles especially around Fairfax
and Melrose until the cops oriented all
their attention around the peaceful
protesters and started hitting them with
batons that's when the first class
started to break I mean that's just the
facts and in Santa Monica it was a very
similar story right how it played out
and when I was watching the looting at
first it was hard to watch you know you
don't want to watch that you know you
feel really badly for business owners
because of what they've had to you know
to endure with quarantine University and
and so you feel terrible about that
nobody wants to see that but at the same
time like 24 hours later I started
having a totally different view on the
looting and and that view is that's what
no justice no peace means it doesn't
just mean a hundred thousand people want
marching down Hollywood Boulevard peace
peacefully doesn't mean just sitting in
front of the mayor's house that's part
of it but it also means like if you if
we can't create a more just society
where everyone has a fair shot everyone
has a fair shake then we are going
that's what no justice no peace means
mmm and it means that there is going to
be times where it's going to blow up the
frustrations going to boil over and
allow other people get the opportunity
to get involved and and loot and so I
think if we look at it that again the
hard truths that is a hard truth we we
created that moment by allowing this
frustration to build and build and build
that's not something that happened
because of them it's not at them them
like well you have to back it up yeah
and look at the seed yeah you know what
you know this this juror
terminated out of these other events
like you have to look at it from a
global perspective and you know listen
there look there that's certainly true
at the same time there are other people
who are just opportunistically out there
shouting who don't give a [ __ ] about no
justice no peace they're just like oh
the cops are distracted I can go
breaking in Nordstrom right now and
totally so then why are that lease so
focused on peace right protesters why
don't you just let that March and that
whole situation was created right
because of the events that unfolded yeah
and and a strategy of orienting your
peacekeeping around the peaceful
protesters versus around okay let's just
let them March and just protect the
buildings yeah and then nobody gets hurt
and there's nobody's throwing bottles at
anybody right you know I mean it's it's
it's choices that are made over and over
again if you go back to the Michael
Brown incident in Ferguson when people
were really pissed off in the streets
and even in Minneapolis people were
pissed off in the streets and I thought
let people be pissed off in the streets
especially now during quarantine no
one's trying to get anywhere right so
like let people be pissed off in the
streets if you start to try to control
that it's going to blow up I mean it
doesn't take brain surgery but for some
reason it's built in people in the
streets are a problem we have to try to
control problems as opposed to just let
it run its course right yeah there was a
sense when Ferguson happened that that
was going to be a tipping moment you
know that was 2014 and it wasn't right
and and I will admit that when the
protests began in Minneapolis that I
couldn't have predicted that it would
catch fire and sweep the nation in the
way that it that it did no me neither
I called my friend Brogan Graham who
lives in Minneapolis after the first
night of protests it's a check in with
him he lives right in the middle of
where all that was going on and during
that conversation we were just talking
and he was telling me you know the
experience of being essentially at
ground zero for that but never once
during that conversation did I think
that this was going that these protests
were going to start happening in
essentially every city and community
across America and now
overseas it's crazy it's a it's it's
very that's what's exciting about it
right that's the excitement that
everyone now is is keyed into this this
real this this other virus that is white
supremacy and wanting to tackle it but
at the same time look at Arab Spring mmm
not to be not to be a downer on this but
I cuz I can see anything happening from
here on out I could see Trump losing 50
or 50 states yeah there's nothing off
the table the table you can go from
Trump losing 50 at 50 to thinning to
winning in a landslide yeah yes yeah I
mean who knows I would doubt a landslide
but he could certainly squeak out a
victory yeah but but Arab Spring like is
the perfect cautionary tale maybe
there's maybe Tunisia came out of Arab
Spring okay and did better but but of
all of the countries I think every one
every single one regressed and look at
Syria so it's we have to continue you
know you're talking about it can't wait
you know what would you suggest your
listeners do like what would you do you
have advice on what to do if you're not
if in addition to protesting or if you
haven't protested things that you can do
did you guys discuss that yesterday yeah
a little bit and I've been doing a lot
of thinking about this I mean I think
that that I'm sympathetic on some level
to the predicament of the white person
in figuring out how to how to how to put
you know whatever they're feeling into
you know a productive Channel right now
I think there's a lot of people who are
hesitant to say anything because they're
not sure what the right thing to say is
and like myself they don't want to say
the wrong thing and so there's a
paralysis it happens with that where
you're like well you know I don't really
you know this is this is you know I
should take a back seat here and let you
know the black leaders lead the charge
here but you know there's a narrative
that this this problem is like going
back to what Toni Morrison said
like this is a white problem yeah and
it's incumbent upon the white people to
fix it and that's gonna require all of
us to look inward and take stock and
inventory of our own behavior change
doesn't happen without interpersonal
change in interpersonal change right
yeah so we have to be fearless in our
interpersonal chain interpersonal change
which starts with interpersonal exactly
yeah yeah right like you've got a
reflect inward and do an honest and open
an objective inventory on your own
behavior and that's what I'm attempting
to do right now and with that comes a
responsibility with how you interact
with other human beings on the one on
one and then on public forums like
Twitter and Facebook and the like and
that means being open to new ideas being
open to challenging your worldview about
your own personal relationship with race
you know being you know courageous
enough to you know read the books like
how to how to be an anti-racist or
watching the documentaries and you know
entertaining perspectives that might be
different or uncomfortable for yourself
you know I think that you know there's
no other there's no way around that like
it has to begin with ourselves and our
relationship to ourselves and our own
you know mining our own you know
consciousness to try to peel back the
layers on on you know our own inner
personal history with race how do you do
that if you have you just is it
something that you just do like you
meditate on it too you journal about it
have you been just talking to you know
Julie or other friends or how is that
manifested for you I mean it's you know
I'm talking to a lot of friends you know
I I will admit also that you know I I
was had you know I was hesitant and how
I communicate publicly about this
because I didn't want to get it wrong
and I had a sense of that paralysis and
I did want to take a beat to like learn
and listen and I think my sense is that
there's a white fear about how the black
community is going to respond
- what a white person has to say about
this especially in the public eye but
the more african-americans that I speak
to they're waiting for those white
voices like there they want you know the
white people to come forward and
acknowledge what is happening right now
and - and to give voice to their
openness for entertaining new solutions
right now so I'm trying to have those
conversations I am trying to listen but
I'm also trying to responsibly message
around that to encourage everybody to
find you know their way of being part of
the solution and I think that's going to
depend on your own psychological makeup
as well right like not everybody is the
person who's going to take to the
streets with a sign but we all have you
know people in our lives and we have
choices around how we communicate with
them about these issues I think that
that's interesting is I love how you
said the interpersonal is an
interpersonal the in this kind of thing
yes you can journal you can you can
write it all out if that's your thing
but also interpersonal can can open the
door to the interpersonal if you have
someone you trust
that you want to talk about these issues
with it could be really valuable to get
on the phone with someone and just talk
them out mm-hm and be completely honest
be completely raw
and and be unafraid of what comes from
it
because that's how you purge it right I
mean yeah it's it's it's interesting I
think it's you know for those that are
on social media it's also about you know
seeking out the the people of color and
the the variety of voices that are
available to you and making the choice
to follow those and to pay attention to
what those people are saying like break
out of your silo yeah that's comfortable
for you and you know seek out the people
that are giving voice to this in a
different way
even if that challenges your own
personal worldview 100 percent I
remember a book that was that kind of
politicized me in a deep deep way when I
was 20 years old was the odd buyer free
rafi of malcom-x mmm which is the
original kind of how to be an
anti-racist right home and it's written
by Alex Haley I think the best ghost
written book ever an incredible probably
the best memoir an American memoir ever
I think that's a good place to start you
know I haven't actually seen that on
some of these reading lists that ever
yeah it's interesting I noticed that as
well yeah yeah yeah but to me that like
and and at the same time I used to read
a lot like when I was 20 21 22 this I
was I read about COINTELPRO which was
this and you know CIA FBI local law
enforcement apparatus that was set up to
crush the civil rights movement
specially the Black Power movement
I read all about that I have not been
reading about that voraciously as I grow
grew old or hmm I've gotten comfortable
on knowing what I knew and feeling like
I'm a pretty good person and you know
and that was good enough even even with
Ferguson happening even with all these
horrible things happening I've not
skewed my life towards getting involved
in police brutality issues or violence
you know I haven't so you know that's
that's my personal failing too right so
and that's from somebody who I care
about these issues a lot you know I've
been studying these issues for a long
long time so you know we all have a lot
of work to do because we don't want this
to be Arab Spring 2.0 right you know we
do want to end up with a 50/50 kind of
landslide and victory and and most
important we don't want our brothers and
sisters getting killed in the streets
anymore
100 percent yeah 100 percent well the
one thing we can all do is we can vote
and I have concerns about what's going
to happen in November right
if the pandemic and coronavirus you know
continue at their current rate or we see
a second wave like listen you know we
were talking we were joking about this
before the podcast and this speaks to
our own my own you know cognitive biases
when I saw videos of people partying at
Lake of the Ozarks what was that like 10
days ago when I was videos were going
around I
remember feeling outraged like how could
these people do this this is so
irresponsible they're just gonna
contribute to the spread of this virus
fast forward to two days ago or three
days ago or whatever it is and you see
this drone footage above Hollywood
Boulevard and it's just you know packed
with thousands and thousands of people
and my heart was full mmm and I thought
what a beautiful amazing thing and yet
in the context of coronavirus that's
perhaps the worst possible thing that
anybody could do you know and and it's
like did we just decide that the corona
virus isn't a thing anymore I think what
it is is there's a hierarchy of concerns
and needs right when we're thinking
about our own personal welfare we want
to sequester we're wearing the masks
we're doing the social distancing but
when a problem so acute and so demanding
of immediate redress and voice we will
take to the streets and there's
something that makes that extra
inspirational but also worrisome in
terms of the inevitable spike in
coronavirus cases that we will
undoubtedly see unfolding over the next
couple of weeks and what is that how
does that bode in terms of what's going
to happen come November we have this
huge election on the horizon there's so
much unrest right now there are so many
questions that are being asked about
what America means for the people and in
the eyes of the world and we're gonna
cast a vote and decide and if that if
we're in a situation in which people
can't access the ballot box or there's
certain measures in place that are that
provide a chilling effect on that that's
going to lead to greater social unrest
and if whoever wins doesn't win by a
significant margin we're gonna see
potentially greater unrest around you
know campaign malfeasance that could
literally lead to the undoing of our
country like I I'm deeply concerned
about that on top of that
we have this problem of of weaponized
social media and fake news you know I
would have hoped that in the wake of
what we saw with the 2016 election that
we would have figured out how to get a
handle on this but instead all we've
seen is a an explosion a mushroom cloud
in the impact of how the media functions
on the psyche of the American voter and
I I despair the more that I think about
that because I don't see a solution to
this problem I see it only being
fomented at an exponential rate and I
think that that means that it's
incumbent upon all of us to be as active
as we possibly can and to make sure that
our voices are being heard and to be you
know on that on that energy that that
personal inward journey to you know
challenge the edifice of our own
information diets to break out of those
silos and to make sure that we're
empowering ourselves with the best most
vetted education possible yeah I mean I
think anything can happen just like you
said this is where the crux of either
we're gonna go into it's not gonna be
status quo no matter what it's either
gonna be a perverted version of the last
four years with Trump even worse or it's
going to be some reimagining of America
which is a beautiful thing but it might
be messy at times but it's a very cool
opportunity like I feel like we're at
this opportunity we haven't been since
Robert F Kennedy jr. was running for
president in 1968 and of course Martin
Luther King and he and him were killed
very very close together and everything
went kind of the nadir came and and the
advancement that we were all hoping for
them pull out of II I mean we I wasn't
alive yet but you know I studied it
America didn't get out of the war they
doubled down we didn't get better we we
did slide back
now you have this same moment but the
good thing about it is that people are
so politicized that even in a pandemic
they're marching shoulder - right
that's the uplifting right aspect and so
like people will turn out I don't think
people are gonna be afraid to vote
because I think we're gonna remember all
those people marching in the streets I
don't think people will be afraid to
vote I think we will vote and Trump's
gonna lie anyway I mean no matter how he
loses he's gonna lie about it whether
whether he if he loses 50 out of 50 it's
almost worse the lie might even be more
believable to some people like how could
I lose 50 states how can I raise all
these red states they love me in Texas
you know that kind of thing mm-hmm so I
think we can't be worried about that
that's just inevitable that's like the
Sun coming up and right in the morning
he's going to lie but what's interesting
is in this reimagining of America that I
think because another great read that I
haven't seen people talk about is the
case for reparations which is Tonya he
see Coates essay from the Atlantic that
kind of launched him in terms of being a
public intellectual and I seeing the
first we're seeing the first bits of
reparations the Kentucky governor has
extended health care coverage to all
black residents mm-hmm
we're starting to see these little bits
of what America could be coming out of
this and and so that's exciting you know
that's very exciting but you're right
there's a lot of work to do this is just
the beginning of something like you had
said to me earlier today not the not
nearly the end it's the just the barely
the beginning yeah and I think on top of
that you know the the there's always
this push with every election cycle like
we got to get the young people out to
vote and like you know it's all about
like trying to you know marshal that
sector of the population to get them to
the ballot box and they never do
right like no matter what it's always
you know I was like whether it's MTV you
know whoever's pushing this like the
young people still don't do it but I
feel like now they are yeah I've never
seen young people more energized around
anything in a civic manner like they are
right now I agree and I think that that
is super
encouraging agreed I think that's to see
this level of political videos from like
whitefish montana um small towns in
Mississippi that's why I think the fifty
to 450 thing is in play losing fifties
is in play for Trump because I'm seeing
stuff I've never seen before but it's
gonna take a concerted effort and people
are doing it you know there's there's a
lot of sorts of efforts to I would love
to see McConnell get kicked on his mmm
its rear end out of town there's lots of
stuff that are in play now that we would
never would have thought before because
of this incredible moment that we're in
what's also interesting is the power of
the moving image and how that plays into
all of this you know the most impactful
filmmaking that's happening right now in
the world is happening on the cell phone
mm-hmm these moments that are getting
captured whether it's you know what we
saw with George Floyd or what we saw
with the Buffalo you know police officer
that knocked over the elderly man or
even with you know the white the white
kids that are looting you know the
Nordstrom or you know whatever it is
like this is all you know playing into
how we're grappling with how to think
about these issues in such a powerful
way because they just get shared the the
the the manner of distribution has
become so democratized that it doesn't
matter that the movie theaters are
closed you know what I mean like we are
being fed these images so in such a you
know in like this waterfall of
information and we're trying to figure
out how to process all of this and then
determine a path forward for this
country at a very you know interesting
time like this is we are living in a
truly historic moment right now I mean
it's partly because the movie theaters
are closed it's because no one's going
to work it's because of I mean
don't think the crowds would be this big
you know there would be some crowds I
mean Occupy Wall Street happen when
everyone was working but like it
wouldn't be to this level if there
wasn't this many people available right
so it's almost because of it in my
opinion and but that's how that's how
history happens right it's like multiple
crazy things all happening in the
confluence of one time in place right
that's how that's what makes history
yeah yeah and to think like think back
to New Year's Eve right and we're all
thinking about what's gonna happen in
2020 nobody could have ever imagined
that we would be in this position it's
quite remarkable it is it is I mean I'm
gonna have I my wife is gonna have our
first kid in cept what's the due date
September 10 and you know we've been
having a fine time we've been staying
very close to home and it's all good but
and she's handling this like a rock star
she's not like poor me at all and I'm
built I'm built to find the higher
ground I'm built to keep it simple like
it's very easy for me to find the good
and in any moment and what I can do to
make my life great on a daily basis I'm
just kind of I've done some work on in
that area and I'm built for that but
when this started to blow up with George
Floyd at first then when we first saw
his video it's very sad you know you
think about bringing somebody into the
world into this world the way we have it
set up it was very sad you know we were
both sad about it and now like a week or
two later I'm I'm excited
you know like I'm stoked to be bringing
another person into this world cuz we
could make it better like we can become
like a Scandinavian bergeon of this
social democracy we can have like
affordable public school great I mean
great public schools and affordable
daycare and a full
portable preschools maybe even free
preschools that set people up we can
democratize nutrition to the point where
we have better food for more people we
can do all those things and it's so
interesting because even though I
studied this before and I've heard it
from friends who have been kind of had
that have to deal with white supremacy
their whole lives the key really is now
I mean the threat is loose and if we
pull that thread and we eradicate that
one thread that's just been woven into
everything mm-hmm
maybe that is the antidote like pulling
that thread maybe that is what's gonna
take to become a better version of
ourselves and I mean look at the NFL
look at the commissioned NFL now right a
guy who was like anti Kaepernick is now
publicly saying he's with the players I
mean I personally you can read that in a
number of ways you can read that as a
political move but but you have to let
whole point of activism is to change
people's minds so to me that's a win and
it's a small way it's a small win but it
was definitely political its political
but it but you you know you do this for
a reason and you don't do it to get
people to change in our minds and then
shame them you do it change people minds
that's a key thing here you know like we
have to allow people to grow and change
and we're in this cancel' culture where
we're holding people accountable for
things that they said and they did very
much in the past yeah we have to provide
people with a path to redemption and we
have to allow people to we have to
celebrate those wins right when people
are able to make those shifts rather
than continue to harp on the thing that
they did in the past I think that's a
healthy you know way to go forward right
now and it's so interesting to think
about like the hullabaloo of her
Kaepernick when that was happening in
comparison to what we're seeing right
now and how relevant that remains to be
yeah I mean what a hero that guy is
crazy yeah yeah yeah and then there was
the videos going around which I didn't
know like the guy who inspired
him to take a knee in the first place
yes like a green beret I don't know why
the green beret guy who was like telling
his version of that story how it all
came to be
his he asked what would be a respectful
way of doing it and the green beret said
Neil right yeah so he was trying to do
it the right way I know he wasn't even
trying to be um yes he was trying to
make a point but he knew I'm he's very
smart so he knew it was gonna cause of
course yeah well one more thing I want
to talk about before we round this down
you're talking about having a child and
you know I've got four kids and there
was a question they came in about you
know how how my kids are doing through
all of this you know it's my it's been a
very interesting time and I've got a 12
year old daughter my youngest turns 13
today it's her birthday today
happy birthday happy Jaya and you know I
look at her and I think about what what
the world is gonna be like for her when
she's 30 40 years old you know what is
the psychological imprint that's
happening right now and how is that
going to be manifest in a society that
exists when I'm long gone right Korona
kids like what is you know she hasn't
been able to see any friends right and
we've been homeschooling her like she's
gone through this period where she's
been incredibly socially isolated like
what is the impact of that and on top of
that I can tell you from the perspective
of my kids you know Joe is turning 13
Mathis is 16 our boys are 23 and 25
they're so politically up to speed on
everything by dint of social media
social medias got a lot of problems
especially with young girls and that's a
whole other podcast but one thing one
one thing that it is serving them well
in is is is how informed they are about
what's happening and how not only are
they aware of what's going on like they
they are fully briefed on all the
arguments about why things should be a
certain way and when I reflect back on
what I was
when I was 13 or 16 I can tell you that
the conversations that I was having with
my friends were not around civil rights
and social justice and the like No and
that gives me great hope that doesn't
mean that this hasn't been a challenging
time for them but I think there is a
there's a there's a there's sort of this
chrysalis moment like they're being
forged for lives of purpose and the
seeds of you know what is right and what
is wrong and what should the world look
like are being kind of like fertilized
at the moment mm-hmm and I think that's
happening all across the world yeah and
this and this doesn't have to be a scary
like this new America this new future
that we're imagining right now together
it can be beneficial for everybody you
know I think that's what what we want to
keep in mind is like I've seen some
stuff online saying losing your
privilege will feel like oppression so
but don't be afraid and III don't feel
like that's actually true I feel like I
don't even understand that well the idea
is right like the idea is that I think
I've seen online is if you if you freely
give up your white privilege it'll mean
you get less or something but I don't
agree with that idea I think that I
think that what we want to do is create
a place where everyone can have a better
life and everyone will benefit so I
don't think there should be any fear of
like you know losing your station in
society or any of that [ __ ] you know
like you know there is there is only us
you know it's like a team it's like
we're we we haven't been behaving like a
very good team in a fractured team but
we really actually are on a team and be
nice if we had some leadership if we had
a coach right that could unify us a
little bit well that's where that's
where old Joe comes in a good old Joe
right
yo he's what we got um I hear you
brother wouldn't it be funny if Bernie I
mean would be great if Bernie was around
here he'd be he'd be screaming at the
cameras so yeah it's amazing that we
don't have him actually talking about it
now yeah I know and you know there's all
different you know I think I think also
it's interesting how relevant some of
the things that Andrew yang was talking
about it's like UB I like them this is
the moment like he was ahead of the
curve and bringing that into public
awareness absolutely that's a real
conversation that we should be having
and entertaining right we've got they're
getting checks yeah yeah yeah he
actually predicted it right yeah yeah
yeah but we need to I think we need to
institutionalize that in a real way not
just this one check right and say we've
dealt with it I mean certainly that
that's not the case no no no no there
needs to be more effort but cool man
that's good I'm not sure if we if we
asked you a lot of these well it was
funny yeah so here's the thing we
started this with the idea of doing and
asked me anything I went on the Facebook
group and said I'm gonna be doing this
and they were like you know over a
hundred comments and Adam dutifully went
through all of them and created a
spreadsheet and I said to you like we're
I'm so long-winded we're only gonna be
able to answer like two or three of
these but the truth is like we have to
talk about what's going on right now so
I understand and realize we didn't get
to we I think we answered two questions
you know out of this but I think this
went well how do you feel oh yeah it was
great man this is it so I think we're
gonna be doing this we're gonna try to
figure out a way to do this on the
regular yeah and and that way we can
sort of you know begin the process of
working through the questions that you
that you want answered and this is
something that that I want to do more of
the podcast obviously has historically
been about putting a spotlight on the
guests and it's not about me but as I
discussed in my my conversation with
James Altucher like he's and I think
he's correct like there is a place on
this show to have looser conversations
where
you know I can share some of my insights
and there seems to be an interest in
doing that so I want to serve that and
absolutely do this more and are the
shownotes are you gonna direct people to
different things they can do reading or
or yeah I'll put some I'll put some
effort into the show notes and try to
provide some some resources so that
people can broaden their horizons and
their perspectives a friend of mine sent
me a Google Doc that had tons of amazing
stuff on it so I might just perfect put
a link so other people can access that
same document which is basically like a
syllabus with all these links and books
and don't see that was Sarah and I think
that would probably do the trick for now
perfect all right man well you want to
come back and do this again with me hell
yeah let's talk about sprouts awesome
yes talk about sprouts it's funny
because I did a podcast with an
environmentalist the other day and just
any talking about anything other than
what's going on right now it just feels
awkward and wrong it's tough it's tough
to get it and yet we're still in the
midst of a global climate emergency it's
not like you know that went away no so
it is important to also talk about other
things but you can't do that unless
you're also engaged in what's happening
right now agreed so and this is the this
is the moment that could unlock a lot of
solutions if we if we let it if we
follow if we walk through the door
together mmm yeah well other than
cooking a new baby yeah what else you
got going on are you working on any long
pieces or what are you writing right I
am I've been working on I've been
wrestling with this novel that I've been
wanting to write for a long long time
and and some I'm almost done with the
very first raw draft of that and then
working on a nonfiction project kind of
at the same time that can't announce
anything about it yet but so I've kind
of been doing those two researching a
little bit nonfiction and doing this
writing this novel and then when stories
come through they come through idea the
most recent thing I did
journalism wise was a a story on surfing
during the pen
for near time sports he also did a story
on the wall I did a story on her outside
yeah that was outside that was in
November late November last year I think
it came out and I went down to Tucson
and was there when they were building
the first pieces of the wall through
preserved and you know National Park
land rights it was through the lens of
the environmental impact of the
environmental impact on cutting off
wildlife corridors and the environmental
impact to the wall because way basically
what's been happening in there you know
while this protests have been happening
he actually expanded these powers of the
federal government to waive the
Endangered Species Act Clean Water Act
Clean Air Act 21 I think it was
environmental laws were waived with a
stroke of trumps pen and that became
legal because of a very obscure law
which which was passed during the W Bush
years mmm
basically as a budget writer and so that
that it was buried and as a budget
writer in this bill that passed easily
and Trump is the first to use it to
sweeping sweep away environmental laws
to build and he did it to build the wall
just recently he did it to build
anything so now you can those same laws
have been waived for construction
projects and cities across the country
on infrastructure stuff right it's it's
a it's a bit of a sleight of hand
because there's so much unrest right now
but behind the scenes there are measures
being taken like this that are erased
from the news cycle that he is able to
accomplish and get away with because
where our attention is placed elsewhere
exactly so you I always watch with that
other hands doing luckily there are
lawyers that do watch that there are
lawsuits I mean obviously the the wall
is being built that's happening right
now but the more recent measure of I
think was last week those will be
challenged in court so no reason to
panic just yet but it just shows you
where there where the mind of this
administration is yeah and it's not it's
not for the benefit of everybody yeah
you talked to Goggins lately I haven't
spoken with him lately I speak with Jen
I spoke with Jennifer more recently but
I have not spoken with
lately but yeah he he blew out his new
yeah like he blew out his ain't stopping
him
he's walking on his hands no I saw that
I was like oh I mean I think of I you
know obviously working with Goggins has
been the highlight of my career I think
about the lessons that he talks about
all the time in my life and and and even
now that's another thing to think about
is is is is making sure you're honoring
yourself and doing the hard work you
need to do no matter what's happening
out in the world the world is always
gonna be noisy and crazy so take time to
do that too I would I would tell all
your listeners you know make sure you're
doing what you need to do too sometimes
it can feel like if me swimming in the
ocean and doing some free diving and you
know it seems like it's not fair you
know why am i doing that when all this
stuff's going on and I just don't pay
attention to that you have to do also
you have to reserve yourself yeah yeah
you got and you know Goggins mantra is
really there are so many things in this
world that you can't control right so
stop being a victim take control of what
you can control and you know take care
of yourself right and and deal with the
hard truths yeah we're dealing with them
yeah and that's what we're dealing with
right now right you know all right my
friend we're gonna be doing this again
so thank you if you want to if you want
to find out more about Adam where's the
best place to track you down
Adam Skolnick comm is my website and
Adam Twitter and answer no Twitter and
Instagram is just at Adam Skolnick out
on school yeah what was Adams vibe oh
that's just you know really origins live
in there in the 90s when email first
became a thing it was Adams vibration
okay Adams vibe at yahoo.com and then
alright that became this thing but I'm I
think I'm gonna fix that at some point
and you know maybe Mike because it when
you're 70 you don't want to be Adams
five
okay awesome man thank you so much I
appreciate it this was super fun yeah
and thanks for having n and I will link
up everything in the show now it's also
linked up Adams stories that he was
talking about and all the good stuff so
go there and that's it for today I guess
I'll just do I can just do the outro now
I appreciate you guys listening to the
show check the show notes for all the
links and resources find out more about
Adam I want to thank everybody who
helped put on today's show Blake Curtis
who video today's show Jason camiolo for
doing the audio engineering Ali Rogers
for portraits my boys Tyler trapper and
Hari for the theme music for the podcast
Georgia Whaley for copyrighting who else
was I forget Jessica Miranda for her
graphics of course awesome
we'll be back here in a couple days with
my conversation with byron Davis and
Phil Allen jr. it's a banger I was gonna
love it can't wait till then
be well my friends peace
[Music]